this game was played between Bobby
Fischer and Samuel rashevsky Bobby plays
E5 there's only one place for the Knight
to go and that's Knight to E7 but this
is a very big blunder as Fisher plays
Bishop takes on F7 and in here black can
easily resign which roshevski probably
saw but as I said they were great Rivals
and he didn't want to allow Fisher to
get this miniature game accomplished he
played Rook takes on F7 but it's
interesting what happens if King
captures an F7 then again Knight to E6
trapping the queen but now the king can
capture here but this is even worse as
black is getting checkmated Queen to D5
check King goes to F5 G4 check King
captures Rook to G1 check King 2 H4
Queen to E4 check after King H5 Queen to
G4 checkmate